yeah hello and welcome to this video
which features round seven of the town
of co tournament again a little bit late
but this began to off like action packed
for me and a blitz tournament on
Saturday and he came on Sunday and on
top of it I was so involved in your
organizing both things which sometimes
is more stressful than the actual games
but everything went fine and just yeah
kept me from doing the video on Saturday
so let's get going they're all seven was
extremely extremely lively round with
many interesting moment so I have to
focus on a couple and it's difficult to
look at absolutely everything but I want
to look at them yeah most of the games
and some important points because there
was an up and down in those games and
can lots of action okay let's get going
with by D playing white against Luke
translated from reading having a tough
tournament and he's especially suffering
with black and we have 11 of his pen
openings he have an idol yeah this is a
very risky approach but lucky I yeah he
does not develop his pieces quickly and
instead uses yes I place many Queen
moves on this year on the nine already
after six rookie one leads to a
situation where white is playing with
the P sacrifice yeah the bishop only
five is all free yeah I can black take
this piece and in the Sicilian though
some P sacrifice a pretty commonplace
and if he takes it now after he takes
can you see that the e file is opened up
and in most cases this is all even a
strategic compensation I mean oftentimes
you don't even need a direct checkmate
to
that this is a position that gives
enough play for the piece yeah here
after King d8 the situation is not
totally clear to me at least not after
somewhat brief look yeah something like
94 could be a good attacking move but
it's not totally conclusive if this is
indeed winning or just extremely
dangerous then really decided not to
take the piece but plays Bishop e7 yeah
this however does not help all that much
after Bishop b3 there are discoveries or
over the place and with the win the
night he played Queen 85 if you would
have taken now white also has nine f5
available I note that this also is a
great attack something like this for
example and 95 is possible also the
capture comes into consideration it's
extremely dangerous of like he played he
played Queen 285 after which way he
decided to sacrifice this piece and note
that he didn't spend much time there it
was probably part of an early analysis
or preparation for this game so he has
sacrificed the bishop for two pawns this
is a very common scenario in the in the
night off where oftentimes white can
sacrifice appease and get black into
discomfort with the king in fact when
there is move now 95 played after an
extremely long think probably just uses
and instead he should play King f7 which
is it seems to be playable for black
even though I'm a little bit concussion
there's a with this assessment it might
be that if you give the computer long
long enough time it will find something
more concrete it is clear that this
position will be dangerous for black in
a practical
this no matter what the objective really
did but it's tough to say from
mathematical point of view let's say is
that grateful wine or not probably 95
came back and then something like a form
is the way to to go it's extremely
unpleasant to play for black but how bad
it is it's tough to say after 95 however
it seems that white position is winning
and he can probably get a winning
position with the capture on g7 but also
with the move before which is what was
played and yeah good luck have to take
it check and 95 note that white avoids
the capture yeah this is maybe also good
but the way it was played was very
strong action in 95 on take sticks cream
into a three yeah and now here there are
a couple of options for for white um
maybe the strongest one is just to
continue the attack and don't get any
material back 96 regained some material
but it seems that was played so that's
what I'm getting at but white can also
just continue the attack and this was
possible with moves between 2 F 3 or 3
CH 5 this attack seems to be decisive if
you just quote them the computers
assessment I mean it is absolutely
obvious for human player that the why
the tech must be extremely strong but ya
know the computer just gives us pretty
much straightforward platforms something
like that so it seems that this is an
immediately decisive attack however it
is not all that all that simple I mean
ye is an excellent attacking player so
if we see the force windy we'll play it
but it is probably not all that
straightforward
and it's tough to say actually what
black should play now as wide as
threatening to take e 796 the engine
gives 96 as the relatively toughest
defense but gasps why the tank is very
strong look we wonder stand your move
using the last piece that is not yet in
play and threatening all kinds of things
maybe down the be far later yeah it
seems to be an extremely strong attack
this was played and had this idea and
with this night you will get to d6 bomb
but 93 there's a funny defense by then
wailing takes takes yeah yeah now if you
do a countywide have white has six poems
like has four poems by this has got two
points for the for the peace and we
would be six yeah now has regained the
exchange in a way so it's in terms of
your pieces is equal why does however
two points out is pawn structure here is
not that great though so this and
actually yeah was a for some progress of
like comparison to having it totally a
lost position technically however it is
still pretty pretty bad I mean the two
pawns are connected on the King side and
black has very little and that he can do
in the game we got to go to this here
and this ending is winning for white
note that it is important if we go ahead
a little bit it's important that white
has an h pawn and he has an h pawn or
sell which fits well with the bishop so
it is the correct bishop
to promote the pawn this might be a draw
if there isn't there isn't an h-bomb for
example if the black Bishop just
imagined would be here on h7s looking at
the f5 Square this position would be a
draw without the h poem oftentimes you
can draw against the two pawns it is a
draw because it's always ready to
sacrifice itself UNF 5 which is not a
draw with H port on the board so even if
the bishop would be there the
sacrificial idea would work because
they're still on edge form that can win
forward in the game laughter couple of
moves and really resigned apologist to
go don't promote there's nothing that I
can do so an opening disaster for the
Dutch player he he fought for a long
while after he probably missed the new
any wind but it was just very bad on the
opening and the next game I want to look
at is the game on I hadn't said one with
the screw screwed up print out one that
is actually working yeah kai Achilles
Aronian let's load this one so that was
an Italian game and yeah ronnian quickly
opened the center with d5 which leads to
a tactical complications right away and
in fact after c3 we should be six Bishop
b3 he played the move f6 and this is
pretty amazing f6 he took a while for
this move and it's really am everything
else would be a two lives this is a big
blunder and that should lose the game
immediately but it didn't because
kayaking didn't play in reputation if he
now would have played c4 he will
probably just win the game
the night is attacked and it a night
before is the strongest try and then c5
and you know double attack double attack
and this is a check so after for example
Queen D Phi and the trade why does the
piece up for just upon and this is what
would have happened so C for basically
wins a piece and the game amazingly kiya
ki did not play that you tried to move d
for that's really weird it's not very
difficult it's the kind of thing that
you would expect such a player to play
in a big scam it's a counterintuitive of
course strategically speaking from a
strategic optical whatever first
impression point of view this move is
terrible United weakens lots of squares
and makes the bishop look awful but it's
just technically good it will speed with
the peace but sometimes this is a big
Kim a big barrier to cross if you that
you consider a move that looks terrible
in the first place once you consider it
and calculate one or two lives then you
work out that you actually win and
somehow ki can didn't didn't spot that
the way it turned out we had lots of
trains and you know the bishops here
also got traded let's fast forward to
that we got this position the simplified
position where white has a slightly
better pawn structure a note like f3
porn Islands white only has two and
white also has the e4 outpost for the
night which looks quite nice this is not
a yes extremely good for white but
definitely more comfortable for him and
it's easy to play and the way it turned
out kayaking was slowly loading on his
slight advantage putting more pressure
on the pawn on d5 an odious triples now
and
regroups this is not fun food like yeah
he's given up all activity on the air
foul and now definitely is in trouble
the b6 square now is a is a new problem
[Music]
here it's already very tough to give
like some advice I think this was a very
well played game by kayaking there was a
small normally couldn't want lots a lot
quicker already on 11 but after that it
is a very nice show of slowly pushing
Aronian back having excellent control
it's tough to say by the way what
exactly Roland did wrong yeah he's
definitely a little bit worse in this
kind of position and then it it gets
worse quite quickly maybe the move c6
ultimately was a problem giving the
knife this additional opportunity yeah
after again my printout it's pretty
screwed up yeah Ronan is trying hard but
it's just too bad a condition yeah you
reached an ending when ending ways two
pawns down yeah I don't want to look at
this all that much in sir not a big
technical task for such a strong player
and kayaking is so a win here for the
challenge of the last world championship
match you missed an early opportunity
but then outplayed Aronian quite
convincingly the next care of the check
is ref is so against alien or two of
them young so is the leader with plus
three score a lien on one plus two so
it's a important game for the standings
the trade of one of those slow Italian
games
nothing much happens i'm going to have
forward a little bit so we have a closed
position from this opening Wes caso has
expanded on the green side having a
little bit more space there battalion
all has account of clay on the King
Solomon f5 and I think then white has a
little bit too much material on the
queenside to get to be really
comfortable black here have some shots
as age 54 the good move breaking the
spinning situation now Alienor sacrifice
a pawn and got a nice active piece
placement probably so now should return
to e2 but he went to age four and this
it doesn't look like a big problem but
it gives black a fantastic position in
fact if you now place correctly the
thing is this is a position where if you
are black yeah you pretty much
immediately notice that you should have
compensation for this pawn I mean this
is a potential actors move we have look
at eight you have Queen to f7 may be
going over or queen coming here in the
right circumstance so all your pieces
are involved in attacking the White King
side and the White King while white has
some material that is kind of stuck on
the queenside the problem whatever is to
evaluate the differences between all the
moves that make and somewhat similar
impression so to work out if Luke f8 now
is better or 95 or Queen f7 it's pretty
difficult and I are not fear plate the
attractive looking move 95 however it
seems that rook be to f8 yeah not caring
about the b7 pole and taking that would
be extremely cheeky but well yeah
doubling on there for this is a lot
stronger if you give
food enough time it will show that black
Sutekh is probably so strong that it is
difficult to defend actually it's not so
easy to analyze the situation what we
definitely can say is that white oops
I'm sorry should not grab here after
green to f7 the situation becomes
extremely critical for white there's
rook f2 coming down again 95 and so on
the biggest issue ever is repair to the
invasion on the second-ranked yeah look
takes be 7-eleven has a bit of an insane
move the best defense according to the
engine is G form after which black rocks
back and again Queen f7 rook f2 these
are the attacking ideas and it is strong
I mean this is not difficult to see but
it's difficult to tell the difference
between this and um the movement was
played which was 95 especially difficult
to tell in a real game if you are
afterwards and you have a computer
helping you it's all easy and relatively
easy but in the game it's difficult to
judge between similar-looking positions
and continuations that sometimes might
be just a transposition move other thing
but it's a difference what you do for
hear the difference is that right could
have played the movie form and the
defense and it seems that he is ok now
then the engine gives us as the best
continuation and it evaluates this at
the end as equal as a better defense for
white West they've so played this move
and again instead of the book plane in
the game before Ruby to f8 seems to be
strong and I'm sorry actually if I was
fine I'm sorry about that before kingi
to analog p8 again now you take Queen f7
group the age again we've been very
strong
looking at this the main problem is that
night before looks like a good defense
but here black has a very strong reply
Knight f3 and stuff like 24 and now they
are seeing the best move of neck is very
difficult you know the analysis here
gives create or Queen f7 potentially
allowing something to go in the H file
it doesn't look good for white but
playing this is another matter working
out the difference between this and this
here actually why can take and this is a
big difference not 94 Queen txt five and
now look T 493 is now note that after
this why has this defense yes because of
this trick right f3 is the better toilet
now we have a tactical sequence which
ends in a position that can only be a
draw they actually agree to draw yes
quickly later it just it just equal him
so there were chances for area not
difficult though there are very
difficult stuff especially considering
then it was played on the limited time
budget of course and they both were
pretty much a long time and we have to
give and raking harikrishna that wasn't
so exciting the only funny moment i
think is ruth one because you see and
raking plain one first see is c3 which
you never CSS on the top level this is
even a name no saragossa opening i have
no idea why this is called the cerec
awesome in fact they transposed to the
Queens gambit declined exchange very
quickly what the game in itself wasn't
so exciting especially if you compare to
happened in the other games so I don't
want to analyze this we had the game
water check want to check audubon which
was a real roller coaster as well re
barn doors for e6b 6 the English Defence
now he's really playing very fresh chess
in this tournament going for fighting
openings in every game the Kings gambit
this is also pretty aggressive choice it
doesn't look like it but it is
aggressive because it gives wide the
opportunity to grab a big center and
then black wants to counter-attack it
what to shake plate Knight c3 which I
think it was a bit of a surprise to me
of course it's not a terrible move but
usually if is clearly considered to be
the most critical one reason for this is
that white avoids to allow the pin in
the first place so for example in a
situation like this is like check White
has the move like King f1 and does not
allow the pin on the night this is for
example of fairly good position for
white ok but this was played and Bishop
before yeah so what we got is a news old
Dutch hybrid in a way the bishop traded
for the knight on c3 and I guess they
fire them I think there are a couple of
alternatives he of course but the white
set up here is quite common putting it
like this with the pawn f3 the bishop
here is blunted and why tries to
long-term exploit his bishop am I think
does this look fairly normal and got a
closed position here g3 is interesting
move yeah black he has to worry about
the night something like 25 is possible
and even G for them is
note this yeah black avoided that went
back to e7 g-form nice back so a
completely closed position eight points
for both sides and yeah there are ideas
however to open up the position and
mostly there is be 45 for white and the
movie 64 black and Arirang waste is no
time you play c6 and it takes the white
center yeah what took it so an
interesting situation here what is some
black trying to do ideally it would like
to establish a piece on d4 and night
would be cool but in order to we get
this in actually needs an ID on you
think Vanda knight on c6 and that's
really difficult to do yeah white wants
to put pressure on the d6 point of
course and maybe try some before
potentially c5 opening up the position
for the bishops and technically off and
in fact it got shot Mia quickly before
take again ok 8 we should be true yeah
so how to evaluate this position
probably equal roughly equal but very
difficult to play and after night at 83
296 h5 force plate and a good move by
the way now honey bunny taking the g4
phone and why probably does not react
yeah we reacted the best way you should
probably take on h5 but she played luke
t 1 and now audubon plays look hm and
this is a bit of an annoyance see how
they look all of a sudden gets this pin
going and white now has to ya face a
difficult decision and it seems that the
next move that he played is not all that
great it looks tempting but it does not
work out all that well you should
probably take on these six which leads
to the a couple of couple of captures
with the simplifications it would be
true this has a chick j and then
probably bishop d1 it doesn't look super
attractive but it should not be all that
bad for white probably it's equal ish if
he continues with with best place in the
game he played this move and c5 that was
the idea of b5 this tactical shot but
that is not all that great it was
difficult to see beforehand oh it's not
so great because of oddi buns reply 94
which is pretty strong he just ignores
that the porn can come to c6 and this is
what happened because he has it quite
firmly under control where the pawn here
is covered well yeah it's just taken
care of with the bishop and difficult to
give wide some good advice in this
position he tried to play g5 when that
should give black a big advantage if you
react correctly you played 98 and it
seems that night h7 was better the the
key idea is that yeah wide of course
have to learn probably covered with h4
it looks like the right move I mean gee
69 m 8 is giving up the spawn but after
H form and black can try this to put
pressure on the pawn or might even try
to sacrifice to check this this is
probably very very dangerous note that
white has very little maneuvering
opportunities
now pieces are very much tied down by
the night and group and the second rank
on the D foursquare that would have been
very strong 987 but he went 98 and I
understand why I mean you have this idea
here put pressure on me file and stop
the porn but the other continuation was
stronger age 49 to 17 f seven maybe was
it was a bit better but it's in such a
complicated position we should be three
and yeah from now on ikea i think what a
shack chains are very nicely check and
now queen bee form yeah that's very nice
the queen is looking at the pawn on d6
and now like only has one move that will
yeah keep her keeping equal and he did
not play it he has to play queen bee
three now that initiate a longest
sequence queen d6 queen bee 298 and we
see six there's to start on a perpetual
yeah White has a perpetual going on like
him okay just gonna check reflect those
check ahead hi this one yeah he's so
going to be checked queen bee three was
the only move that alley bar now had to
play but he did not he played Bishop b5
and it seems that after Bishop b5 white
could have gotten a very good position
with rookie one taking on d6 next it
wasn't late 11
I also don't think it's a super
intuitive move the move that motor Shack
plays also did perfectly reasonable yeah
something like this cleaning 7 and then
just a slow move with doc bishops III I
mean white cannot take like this because
of rook takes bishop so he prepares it
and in fact he doesn't have anything
right something like channel if you move
the book and white takes the problem is
that with the d6 point falling then
those pawns are also very weak probably
impossible to hold they obviously cannot
be covered by the bishop and the night
is completely yeah he'll position to to
help with those pawns yeah this was
player ever still not another terrible
move but look the one more stronger yeah
King and 75 was probably better and now
what the Sheikh could take this yeah and
I mean this is a good position for white
very good position for what was able to
take this 26 Queen deform or all looking
Liza so if we do a quick summary it was
a real fighting game and audubon
probably we are could have could have
won the game earlier with 9 h 7 he was
in an in okay shape after that but then
he stumbled into a really bad position
and now watch the shack has this on the
board now if the porn up he's got a very
good bishop on me too it looks like a
fantastic position after Queen c3 you
probably will win this on the non one
Queen to see three but he played rue k 1
and that surprisingly surprisingly gives
up his advantage I leave and now
captured and played Queen a 7 and the
point is that he is ready to invade on
these three
and this is extremely annoying as the
Queen and Bishop of both on the f3 pawn
this is correct and now Queen III and
all of a sudden Black is okay it's
really remarkable yeah he now here to
take an f3 everything hang on f3 who
takes and now know that all of a sudden
black has two passes as well and it's
got potential Nigel the White Knight is
also in some problems it doesn't have
any great squares it seems that the the
best play now is there for me at least
not extremely intuitive g6 and then put
the night on v3 play on a 3 i'm sorry
just activate it and go from there
potentially king g3 is next end and for
something like that just that the
lightest is more active from h3 probably
equal then this is what he played yeah
first of all black cannot take this I
mean he can but it is not particularly
good this ending is better for white
winning not sure but it's definitely
better for white this is going to stop
the beep on and then thus one gets
through unrolling so this was played by
honey bun and again you should probably
play g6 now and then 9 h 3 what a shaker
ever played c7 and now the bishop is
stopping in a pond this might still be a
draw objectively but it's not easy King
III g6 King be too there's a critical
moment a bit later check right couldn't
take you check
so here a little bit later f 4 b 3b 3b
should see eight probably was better but
okay King see 3 in the eighth year and
now that's a bit mysterious now what to
check now plays c8 Queen and why not f5
and looked extremely natural after the
trade and okay Black has to take on f5
you take here and this is probably wrong
it's probably at all at once they what
the engine gives as well if this okay
and King comes out the bishop is
currently dominating the night and even
if the night gets in to get it gets into
it yeah why just extremely quick here I
think it's a draw following at five and
then yeah it stopped which gives 0 it's
a pretty good indicator check also just
biological means why would you play that
it's really a bit mysterious why not get
rid of more pawns here the bishop is
getting active and the night can easily
be activated 10 comparison here on water
shake resigned the night will come to
snow to f5 and then H forms will be
falling so it's an absolute fighting
game ups and downs both sides could have
warned then you had turned it into a
lost position it was a big drama on okay
so let's see what's what is still never
we know how many years run I think we
actually looked at almost everything
besides one game of course that is going
to be the final one that I check if I we
actually report and also quite
interesting report was better that ok I
their their their limits and to what we
can check the game Carlton giving is the
final ones that I'm looking at because I
think this has implications for the old
tournament in a way and so I don't want
to look at everything in detail the game
is extremely long but called uplinks
let's let's play back cards already in
the world championship match so not a
huge surprise um they got a fairly
standard looking positional ever hear
the hanging porn situation with f4 and
this looks like a position where it
should be between equal and slightly
better for white m here and what I'm
surprised about a little bit is am I am
a bit surprised about how you e places
now because if he decided to take on f3
and only two don't trade down into this
ending and this ending here looks um
looks unpleasant I just think it's very
unpleasant and I don't know exactly why
that was necessary i mean he's of course
much stronger than I am but I would have
liked the idea to play this ending I
mean okay and if we can't calm but
that's not really the the greatest
opponent to play an end game against the
thing is white has an easy plan with a4
a5 plan and it feels just a little bit a
little bit of
oh yeah joyless task to play this in the
game cowden got some advantage here he's
got the sea porn passer and slowly very
slowly as he does it press this position
former it was a real typical game of the
world champion and he's got the sea porn
and he's got the better minor piece the
bishop is stronger give me defense by
trading this is a good defensive
strategy you want to trade especially
palm why is better the bishop is a lot
stronger as we can see and the way it
turned out he could not hold on this
material much longer and why this just
to actor and de pont held a little bit
later I first this one I know you can I
realize this but I want to get get to
the to the main point here why does
extremely actors here this is attacked
the Epona's under pressure and you can
barely move now you try to inform and
the h5 got taken III yeah okay so we
give a check and the e pawn is rolling
this is however not an issue at all
White has a strong move Bishop f3 so
what's the point yeah the point is that
after queening yes cops had to check
king of eight yeah check King g8 that
was the only move yeah and now yeah this
is a position that will be nice for for
the viewers to to check because this is
the chance where you can try to find a
move that is better than the word
a movement it's not something ingenious
that you need to find yeah if you check
this position in your calculation what
should you look at first it's checks and
captures in this particular situation
there isn't a great capture available
but you have a couple of checks a very
obvious check is the check on f7 this
was played by Colin but you have to look
at all the tall chicks and there is also
the check and we note that if you check
into poses there's 98 which is just
throwing your piece away doesn't make
any sense let's Ruby 8 which after Kenny
takes have a look wins everything and
then there are the king moves and black
has those two king moves so we will step
forward it doesn't matter where it goes
again look at the checks look f7 check
yes King age 6 here we see that it
didn't matter where he went yeah this is
the same kind of situation King age 6
and now look at age eight so that's
actually made in three moves check
checkmate so the world champion here
could have played rooks the a check look
at sound check and check next me the
only option for gearing to prevent the
maid would have been rupee aid which I
needs to this disaster and worldwide us
and we'll get two pawns up so amazing
really amazing looks the eight is the
most obvious move basically in the
position almost and somehow with 12 of
time on the clock carbon didn't play it
I mean it wouldn't have been
unreasonable for giving to reside here
absolutely not I mean it's after Bishop
where three many players were probably
resign and somehow cars didn't play that
he played Bishop f7
maybe he thought that that wins as well
it actually does win but rook c8 was
check-check face except if you can do
that do it so you replaced King edge aid
check check king of six and now now cows
have 15 minutes on the clock and now has
to find the best move and if he plays
the correct move the position if the
total win but he still does not do it
yeah here he played to move yet booga h6
check instead Bishop c4 was winning your
wife said winning rook f7 is one of the
one of the key ideas and of course the
night is hanging with check so you know
what's going on black does have checks
like this but after teenage 3 it's over
there are no checks available anymore
and black is not escaping in something
like this I yes it's pretty strong okay
and the Queen gets lost and this is
shattered comparable situation it's a
win instead see playbook h6 check and TV
five and now things are not clear all
the sudden this is attacking the look
and the best that you can do now is what
he did he played this okay and when did
you this ending look at Bishop plus two
pawns against the Queen and this is a
very unusual material just
illusion of course and you cannot just
look it up in a book yourself and my my
take is probably should end in a draw um
but I think one point is here actually
that white has got the wrong bishop that
gives black some additional additional
ideas to draw and we see one of them in
the game we can fast forward a life
check check it was a long game yeah yeah
we're nearing move 100 Ches Ches Ches
Ches Ches Ches okay move 115 and here we
see a pre drawing idea we got five wins
the Queen but ends in this theoretical
wrong with the wrong bishop yeah it's no
way here to learn to win like us going
into the corner and makes it wrong in
fact they played it out and why not
actually think this is a good idea just
play it out it's quickly done Stanley
and it offers people who don't know this
draw the chance to see it played out in
a real game so black cannot win for a
fight cannot win because black is just
sitting in the corner and you're going
to make progress you have to try with
why to advance and this is the best that
you can get and it's still a stalemate
now you're always stalemate in the black
me unfortunately so a big miss by the
world champion instead of getting into
an unbeaten plus three score joining the
need and he made a draw in this marathon
game against the giri who is soon i
think a very comfortable opponent for me
when you're speaking during last year's
could convincingly but it still feels
very difficult into actually yeah get
get the real get there to point it so it
really up and down spectacular round i
hope you enjoyed the coverage and the
coverage of round eight is also going to
be on shortly thanks for watching my
line
[Music]